what's up everyone we're back with
Naveen Jane
we are gonna be talking about evolution
and the microbiome Naveen you kind of
blew my mind with this your your toe
you're talking about how microbes
decided to make humans in order to
spread themselves across the world and
how this is kind of interesting could it
be potential that humans make AI to
spread AI
across the universe you know so one
could argue in fact is it the microbes
that actually created humans and even
though we may believe that we are
creating AI what if the AI actually
created us to spread itself so what if
the microbes were are actually the AI
you think about it and we all are so
proud of being human right and what I
think I find really fascinating is that
we as humans we have more foreign cells
in our body than human cells but they're
just nothing right if you look at it
from the perspective how many all good
number were about forty trillion or so
on bacteria human yeah know what I'm
talking about
in terms of with the in terms of number
of cells yeah approximately okay yeah
but in terms of look at that just the
quantity of the microorganisms living
inside one person all the humans on this
planet Earth and we had 5,000 planet
Earth there's still be less number of
humans than there organisms living
inside our gut think of the for a second
now if you look at what makes us who we
are is the genes that are expressed in
our body our human DNA that we get from
our mom and dad only Express about
20,000 genes and the microbes in our gut
are producing somewhere between 2
million to 20 million genes that means
at best we have one percent human right
and that to me is mind-boggling but
what's really interesting is who really
makes the decision we talk about this
free world that we have this free world
the humans actually make the dis
they do and it's been proven time and
time again by the neuroscientist that
actually when they look at your brain
and they are able to predict before you
make a decision the decision you're
gonna make
that means somewhere along the lines the
decision is getting made where could
that be before we become conscious
before we become conscious of it right
so it's very interesting is that I have
this tongue in cheek II story that
you're referring to that how I believe
this could have happened even though
this is a tongue-in-cheek story there is
tremendous amount of scientific evidence
to suggest that is actually what is
going on that means we evolved from
these microorganisms and the
microorganisms to some extent are using
the humans as a container to spread
themselves right so and really now so
let's let me give you the
tongue-in-cheek story about how it could
have all started right so he's built
this on the scale of billions of years
versus on the scale of just my lifetimes
80 yes
but imagine so we all know that you know
we started to see the organisms on
planet Earth
about 3 and 1/2 4 billion years ago the
humans only evolved in the last couple
of million years yes so how did the
humans come to be so imagine if this was
the scenario that happened that one day
all of the organisms got together and
say we're sick and tired of living in
this small space in Africa we want to
take over the world and they all looked
at each other and one of them said
master I have an idea what's your idea
what if we can create something that's
bipedal and two years of us could live
right inside it we all we have to do is
keep this thing healthy we can make it
crave any food we want is going to run
around and find all the food we want for
us and guess what he's going to go
everywhere in the world
it's going to poop everywhere and it's
going to spread us around and we're
gonna take over the world and they
decided they were created in humans as
soon as they created humans was there a
step along the way of the ripped
reptiles and there and the fish in those
are all the you know all the trial and
errors they went through you know oh how
about this and about
that and said I don't and finally found
the perfect thing that you wanted and
they call that humans right and once the
humans got created they start to worry
just like today we have Elon Musk you
know smoking weed and talking about how
AI is gonna take over the world
and if a I really became smarter than
human beings what will happen to us
human beings and we all worried about
that all these organisms had the same
feeling oh my god what have we just
created what if someday this human thing
becomes a smarter than us yeah and they
all reassemble the same master master
what have you done we created humans
aren't you worried someday they're gonna
become smarter than us they're gonna
digitize consciousness and just go
through the cosmos without us yeah what
are we going to do about it
what is it destroy us master cease oh
don't worry we took care of that problem
on day one how is it master I'm gonna
tell you a secret inside the human cell
this thing they call mitochondria they
don't remember it is one of our
bacterial brother
that's right inside them it is the one
that supplies all the energy to their
cell we talk to it all the time and
anytime they go out of control we shut
the energy factory down they are dead
Master that's really brilliant but what
you're still forgetting is they starting
to develop this thing called brain what
I'm gonna do about the brain part master
see that's the first thing we did
remember we live all in the gut we put a
direct connection from our gut to their
brain very sir they call that a vagus
nerve and they thought they're gonna
name it after Las Vegas thinking what
happens in the gut is going to stay in
the gut they were wrong what happens in
the gut goes everywhere in fact the
things that makes them feel good the
serotonin thing we don't let them
produce much of that 90% that we produce
it ourselves
in fact we control their decision-making
we control their amygdala which is all
of their mood emotions and behavior we
control their prefrontal cortex we
modify their micro RNA
we but you know what we're really really
smart we make them think they are the
one who are making the decisions but
like a good leader that's what all good
leaders do at the end of the day we are
the one who are pulling all the strings
sitting here they're simply the puppet
so sit back relax we have taken over the
world
and that's how they must evolve that's
now it's a cool story but in this
interesting part is now going back to
the science part if you google there is
a nature article that was published
about three months ago that shows that
how microorganisms in our gut control
our amygdala prefrontal cortex in our
brain for their own benefit yeah Wow in
fact there is another research paper
just came out two days ago about
mitochondria and microbiome
communicating with each other in
longevity and any aging so they are able
to essentially control the aging as a
microbiome is essentially gets to be
imbalance they did a study of 1,600
people 90 year olds and they were able
to predict which one of them is actually
healthy and which one is sick simply
looking at the microbiome because the
microbiome of the people who were
healthy was similar to the one they were
30 years old right so the microbiome is
the one that works with mitochondria
your energy Factory and essentially
keeps us healthy alive and young so you
want to keep that 15 or 25 year old
microbiome as long as possible and the
means that means is constantly adjusting
what you're feeding them because at the
end of the day they only get to what you
give them and they make you crave the
food they want remember yes and this is
okay great this is gonna be a good segue
into the next section um we'll be
talking about the nuance of the
microbiota all right cool